التصريحات الرسميه التي صدرت صباحها اليوم
انه تم العثور بالفعل على الجثث العشر
لركاب او ضحايا طائر الموجوده طائره
وبالتالي كما انه سبق اكلت هيئه الطيران
المدني تواجد
على متن هذه الطائره وبالتالي لم تعد هناك
اي شكوك حول مقتل الانجيل في حاله التحكم
الطائره الان لجنه التحقيقات تعمل على
اسباب سقوط وتحطم الطائره ومعي الخلفيات
التي ادت الى ذلك كما سبق واعلنت التحقيق
انها قد ستقوم بالتحقيق وفق اتهام
بالانتهاء قواعد سلامه الملاحيه
وتشغيل وسائط النقل الجوي
لا شك ان مقتل اثار موجه من الحزن لدى
قطاعات القوميين الروس خاصه هذه القطاعات
التي كانت تحظى برعايه بري وتمويل مؤسسه
بشكل عام الشارع الروسي يطرح كثير من
التساؤلات حول عمليه سقوط الطائره وحول
مقتل في هذا التوقيت باعتبار انه منذ
اسابيع قد تمرد ضد وزاره الدفاع وكان يسعى
لازاحه قياده هيئه الاركان باعتبار انهم
بالتقصير في هدايا والتهمم ايضا بانهم
يعني يتراجعون عن تنفيذ اهداف العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكر